candid
truth what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're GNA
talk about the truth and we're gonna get
candid with it I had to talk about this
drone thing everyone is talking about it
right now like every time I click
homepage it's live news it's somebody on
YouTube everybody's talking about it and
rightfully so there are things flying
around in the sky and people are
confused some people are scared some
people are like whatever it's really
weird to see that we're living in a time
when you can have drones invading cities
and people are like oh that's kind of
cool whatever keep on shopping like we
have been so desensitized by the media
by predictive programming that hardly
anything phases us anymore it's like oh
aliens came to the White House H I know
that was like oh well got to go to work
it's really crazy but I I was going to
talk about this like four days ago like
Monday I was trying to talk about this
but I was so wrapped up in the book
thing by the way if you guys aren't
familiar with the book aby's strange
dreams is a reality in two weeks this
book is going to be printed because of
you guys and your generous giving Abby
strange dreams is coming out and hey
maybe more will come in and we'll we'll
produce more I want this message out to
the world there's kids all around the
world that need to go what need to know
what's going on right now you wouldn't
believe how many attacks have come
against getting this book out to
Children teaching about spiritual
warfare the only book that I know of
this teaching children about spiritual
warfare and what these alien beings are
and so while I was wrapped up in that I
kept I doing research and I'd run out of
time doing research run out of time all
the way until now and Monday basically I
just wanted to get on here like Alex
Jones and be like look we all knew
police state was coming they're saying
that these drones are to sniff out bombs
and and oh don't worry they're not
they're not a threat we don't know where
they came from or what they are but
they're not a threat just uh stay calm
and carry on as they once said years ago
and everybody would just you know kind
of go along with life while police state
rolled out that was basically my
thoughts on it I was like this is police
state we've saw this coming for years
now for me since uh the end of 2011
I was God showed me that this stuff was
coming and so I was like what they're
doing is just distracting people and
saying don't worry go back to sleep it's
just drones we don't know where they
came from or what they are but it's okay
and and just releasing police state like
New World Order like all these movies
Skynet uh
Oblivion Minority Report it was
basically coming to that but the more I
looked into this topic the more the news
changed their tune the more interviews I
watched the more footage I watched I was
like wait this this is even deeper even
crazier than I expected that's that's
crazy enough already New World Order and
drones and controlling humanity and all
that but it's actually something else we
talked about some of this before if you
guys watched disclose documentary or you
watched the live stream the other night
we talked about that
coincidentally December 20th
2019 was the unrolling out of the space
force under the Trump Administration
last time he was in December 20th 2019
remember that date in your mind because
what was happening around the same time
all these years we've never had a space
force we had Army
Navy uh Marines but we never had space
and so now we're protecting the land the
sea the air and now space why are we
what are we worried about from space how
come all these years thousands of years
that we've been on Earth we've never had
to have a
military defending Earth from space but
in December 20th 2019 space force
happened and
coincidentally if you look at this this
is the CDC Government website I asked
when did did the whole pandemic thing
happen and this is what it says late
2019 December 12 2019 this is like
December 12 that was days before the
whole space force came out December 31
Early 2020 in January 1st 2020 the human
Seafood wholeness Market in Wuhan is
closed amid worries in China so
basically the beginning of 2020 is when
this came to America from China
supposedly this is all in finger
quotations guys but this is the official
story right
so December 20th 2019 the end of 2019 we
get a space force and
then early 2020 a month later we have
the whole pandemic thing so like
everything's locked down mask up six
feet apart stay home save lives get the
jab all that stuff and was like the
world changed
overnight also
coincidentally um so it was March 11
2020 was the official date that they
declared that it was officially a
pandemic so January February March three
months later four months after less than
four months after the space force
happened we had this huge lockdown the
whole world is locked
down I looked up was there an increase
in UFO sightings during the Corona virus
and look these these articles are back
from 2021 2020 2023 and it says UFO
sightings Spike dramatically during the
Corona virus very interesting UFO
sightings up nearly 50% during Corona
virus is there any connection between
UFO sightings and covid
so I don't know like is there a is there
some kind of parallel how come we had a
space force then everybody's locked in
and they have to stay home and all of a
sudden sightings go up like crazy is it
just a coincidence that now we're now
we're officially prepared the military
is prepared for these things that are
now increasingly being seen all over the
world I don't think that's a
coincidence um military.com this was
back in 2021 it says as part of the
newly ped covid-19
relief legislation lawmakers are
demanding answers from the US
intelligence agencies and the defense
department on potential existence of
UFOs and other unidentified area
phenomenon so for some reason wrapped up
in this whole covid relief
legislation they're demanding we need to
know everything you know about UFOs like
what's the connection what's the
connection in UFOs and Co why are they
even in the same documents the same
court hearings but they were and there
was this huge
5,593 page bill that said that the that
the military or the government has 180
days to turn over all the information it
has about
UFOs why this is this is crazy I'm I'm
like taking you through history December
20th 2019 space
force January to March pandemic lockdown
everything things upside down you got to
you better wear a mask you better stay
home you know uh secret police like take
a picture of your neighbor if they're
not wearing a mask and send in the
report look out in New York the mayor of
New York or whatever was saying send in
a picture we'll we'll get them and and
we'll actually reward you for it they're
changing everything this was like
communism coming in all of a sudden and
wrapped up in this thing is also we want
to know everything you know about UFOs
because coincidentally UFO
sightings have gone up 50% and one news
reporter even said double the sightings
since the pandemic happened so Logan
Paul if you don't know who he is Logan
Paul he's a YouTuber and he has over 23
million
subscribers so YouTube is now the new TV
we grew up on TV and movies and
celebrities and uh you know we wanted to
be like the movie stars right right but
now YouTube are the new movie stars
they're the new influencers nobody
watches tv nobody has cable everybody's
tuning into YouTube because now it's
like you know reality TV took off back
in the 90s and stuff and so now this is
like reality like it's you YouTube It's
UT TV so now you get to have people that
you feel like you connect with so is
there a push for this whole alien agenda
thing through influence people like
Logan Paul with over 23 million
subscribers check out Donald Trump our
now president was on a show with Logan
Paul which is just interesting when did
you ever see a president getting on like
a really hip show and doing an interview
with some you know young young dude
that's got his own show it just never
happened before you back in the day
presidents weren't like cool you know
they're like they're the leader and now
ever since like Obama came out they were
like oh man vote for Obama he smokes
weed like man he's cool he you know he
was like in a in a Snoop Dog video or
something like things got different and
now you see people all holding up giant
signs of a president's head and they're
wearing I mean especially when Obama
came into office I I was a valet at a at
a hospital I saw the the presidential
family on keychains I saw people wearing
an Obama scarf like a jacket that had
the Obama family on it when did we start
doing this like this is communist China
right here like where you have pictures
of your leader on your clothing and on
your keychain and a picture frame in
your house crazy but that's where we're
at so Donald Trump in full I've never
seen this dude outside of a suit but he
was the president during this
conversation I'm guessing but listen
what he says I met with Pilots like
beautiful Tom Cruz Boller okay handsome
Perfect People sir there was something
there that was round in form and going
like four times faster than my super jet
fighter
plane and I look at these guys and they
really mean it yeah and am I a Believer
no I probably I can't say I am but I
have met with people that are serious
people that say there's some really
strange things that they see flying
around out there so you have the
influencers of the world 23 million
subscribers he can get Trump on a show
and he can broadcast and millions of
people are going to watch that and see
wow the president is talking about like
he interviewed real Pilots that are
saying they really see strange stuff
that defies physics so the stage is
being set has been for years I mentioned
another
uh show that when I was growing up I was
intrigued by this topic checking out
books on ghost and Aliens when I was in
elementary school when Fox television
showed the alien autopsy like I thought
I was like getting the inside scoop like
I was like whoa it's getting out the
leak they leaked it out the aliens are
real there's no such thing as a leak on
mainstream controlled television
controlled mainstream propaganda there's
no such thing as they leak no such thing
as a
whistleblower all of the media is
propaganda you can watch these clips
where they show news after news after
news all saying the same script it's all
talking head garbage but when I was
young I thought I I'm I'm finding out
the secret they're I want to know the
truth and they're trying to hide the
truth from me that
is that's the tactic of Satan Satan's
tactic through the government
is to put the hands put the power in the
hands of the people make the people feel
like they're empowered and we demand you
stop hiding this you tell us the truth
so they're going to release little
things here and there a little leaked
file here a little whistleblower here
and and you know the
official the the official hearings will
all just be like well we're we're not
sure what it is uh swamp gas weather
balloons but the leaks the
disinformation and the misinformation
keeps coming out to make you feel like
you're you're catching on until the
people say we demand to know the truth
you tell us the truth we don't care if
there's aliens we already know they're
here tell us the truth and then they'll
say all right you asked for it aliens
they're real and they're Among Us and
they've been watching us for years and
we've been communicating for for a long
time but we didn't think you could
handle it so we we had to lie to you and
that's what I I believe is happening
right now is the they're making the
people feel
empowered so according to a 2018 Pew
research survey about four in 10
American adults who identify as
Christian believe in
psychics this is part of a broader trend
of many Christians also holding belief
that beliefs that are sometimes
considered quote unquote New Age this
such as astrology reincarnation and the
presence of spiritual energy and
physical objects so already we we see
this Falling Away happening in the
Christian church like Christians aren't
holding to a thus sayeth the Lord what
does the Bible say they're actually
believing in New Age philosophies at
this point four about four in 10 so that
40% of Christians believe in new age
beliefs that's where we're at today I
want to show what Alice Bailey believed
because in January
1946 the new age theosophical Guru
prophesied that Christ would return
sometime after ad. 2025
interesting theosophists ident identify
Christ quotequote Christ as being
identical to a being they call mraa
that's the new age
Christ to
inaugurate the age of Aquarius thus this
event will be according to Bailey the
new age equivalent of the Christian con
concept of the second coming so this new
Ager who channeled and did all these
things writings uh automatic writing she
was predicting that Christ or mraa would
come sometime after 2025 when we entered
into the age of Aquarius and they're
comparing that to the second coming of
Christ Bailey stated that St Germaine is
the manager of the executive Council of
the Christ thus according to Bailey St
germain's primary task is to prepare the
way for the second
coming uh but not the second coming of
Jesus Christ because we know if we read
prophecy we know that Jesus isn't coming
to to touch the earth when he comes he's
coming like lightning flashes from the
East to the West every eye will see him
the dead in Christ will rise first those
who are alive and remain who are
believers will be caught up to meet the
Lord in the air and so the dead and the
righteous living are going to be caught
up to meet the Lord Lord in the air and
forever we will reign with the Lord for
a thousand years in Heaven until the
thousand years is finished when we come
back with Christ to judge angels and
that's when Satan is going to be there
on Earth and the wicked are going to be
resurrected it said the rest of the Dead
live not again until after the thousand
years was finished and that's when the
wicked are are judged but Christ isn't
going to touch the ground when he
returns so if we see any being I don't
care how how Supernatural it is doing
signs and wonders and miracles it's
going to deceive millions of people if
we don't stand on thus saith Prophecy in
the Bible if we believe our senses we're
going to say this being is Supernatural
this being has fixed all the problems of
the world has fixed our pandemics has
fixed climate change has cured cancer
all these things this has to be Christ
and even atheists are going to believe
at that point because they're the ones
that are saying I won't believe it until
I see it and guess what Christ isn't
coming until an antichrist comes first
until Satan comes appearing as Christ
and doing lying signs and wonders
Miracle workking demons the Bible
says and so many people are going to be
deceived by their senses by what they
saw because they didn't read prophecy
Jesus said if they say he's in the
desert don't go if they say he's in the
secret chamber don't look Christ knows
that this is so deceptive that there's
no way that we could rationalize it that
you will be deceived if you even go and
look at it yourself you're going to fall
for the the Trap you're going to fall
for the deception because it's that
convincing and that's what Christ said
if he's in the desert or in the secret
chamber don't go it's not
him so this is where this writing comes
from um Lucius trust.org it used to be
called Lucifer trust but they had to
change the name because that was just
too inyour face back in the early 1900s
the late
1800s but there they have an article
about what happens in
2025 and so the books of Alice Bailey
the externalization of the hierarchy
section four stages in the
externalization of the hierarchy this is
talking about Spiritual Beings that are
going to externalize themselves they're
going to manifest and they're predicting
that in the year 2025 this was written
back in like
1914 so here it says uh okay December
1919 and notice what it says it says the
subjective basis of the new world
religion man this is biblical prophecy
like anyone that's ever gone to a a
prophecy seminar knows that in the end
times there's going to be a one world
government a one world religion that's
enforced worldwide
bow to the Beast system or be beheaded
take the mark in your hand which is
obedience or in your forehead which is
the beliefs of your mind if you take
that Mark of
worship uh you'll be okay you'll be able
to live but if you don't receive that
Mark you will be persecuted you'll be
imprisoned you'll be
beheaded and you're going to have your
ability to buy and sell cut
off but this is this is what's crazy is
there predicting this new world religion
and they think it's a great thing a lot
of people will think it's a great thing
because the Bible verse says when they
say peace and safety sudden destruction
will come upon them so there's coming a
time that's going to look like peace
it's going to look and safety it's going
to look like hey the world is like a
Utopia right now like every you know
this being that came he got rid of all
our
diseases um he taught us how to love
each other because all Rel really are
worshiping the same God you know don't
don't judge the Buddhist don't judge the
Muslim they just worship a different way
who are we to
judge and so it's this one world
religion and it says in 2025 is a
jubilee year for the Christian and
Jewish calendar that is also the focus
of Prophecy the Ageless wisdom suggests
that in the 25th year of every Century
there is a gathering on the subtle
Plains of all Masters sa Masters like
ascended masters in the New Age Saints
you know Catholics they believe in the
Saints rishes and enlightened beings
okay even people think aliens are
enlightened beings and over time this is
followed by significant changes in
humanity because of the growth of Soul
values the sense the the sense of
synthesis the inclusive Spirit oh
goodness the inclusive Spirit and the
rejection of
separatist so we can't have division we
can't be separate we got to we got to
reject that and we got to have an
inclusive Spirit it sounds so good right
uh by people of intelligent Goodwill
there are grounds for expecting the
worlds of
soul and of outer human living to be
increasingly aligned in the years and
decades following 2025 so this is like a
paradigm shift I believe 20125 is like
the start of something crazy this might
mean people who have achieved some
measure of spiritual enlightenment
emerging as leaders in all manner of
human Affairs uniting the hundreds of
thousands of world servers from every
part of the
planet initiating a resistance in global
culture and civilization prophecy even
suggests the emergence at some undefined
time of a Christlike figure recognized
by people of spiritual inclinations in
all faiths isn't that interesting all
faiths are going to be deceived by this
Christlike figure this is this is coming
from Alice Bailey Just for anybody
that's like maybe confused on what we're
reading right here this is from lucious
trust.org by a spiritist Channeler uh
Alice
Bailey rooted in the realities of the
world of 2015 with all the problems of
our age and all the aspirations for
Unity and diversity symbolized by the
sustainabil sustainable development
goals it is a good time to ponder what a
new spiritual dispensation my goodness a
new spiritual dispensation might mean
for a post 2025 world and pondering such
a possibility we become naturally invoc
invocative
so this is a prediction about what's
going to come after 2025 that could be
the day after 2025 that I think that
2025 is Satan's plan for like this is
where it all starts this is the Paradigm
Shift The Age of Aquarius the the thing
that's been predicted for years and
years the externalization of the
hierarchy and it's just is it a
coincidence that we have this far
right-wing president Donald Trump and
project 2025 that gives him the power
and authority to enact religious laws
laws this is crazy so let's
continue so it says thus a great New
Movement is proceeding and a
tremendously increased interplay and
interaction is taking place this will go
on until ad.
2025 during the years intervening
between now and then very great changes
will be seen taking place and at the
great general assembly of the hierarchy
the Great General Assembly this is like
United Nations for Spirits for
demons uh the great general assembly of
the hierarchy held as usual every
Century in 2025 the date in all
probability will be set for the first
stage of the external externalization of
the hierarchy present cycle from now
until that date is called technically
the stage of the
Forerunner so this we're living in the
stage of the Forerunner right now the
setting the stage literally it is
Preparatory in nature testing in its
methods and intended to be a re
revelatory in its techniques and results
you can see therefore as chohan's
Masters initiates World disciples
disciples and
aspirants affiliated with the hierarchy
are all at this time passing through a
cycle of great activity so she's talking
about all these different Spirits
ascended masters disciples they're all
part of this hierarchy that's going to
have an externalization after this
meeting that's going to happen insane so
I don't know if anybody saw this
interesting tweet or I don't know what
you call it now X post Elon Musk this is
his
official Channel I don't know what you
call the this is his official EX post
but this is yeah Channel I guess his
page Elon Musk you see the
checkbox he said in September
30th drone swarm battles are coming that
will Boggle the
Mind where did he get this information
from this is the guy who's the richest
man in the world who's dressed in a red
satanic outfit that has a baffet with an
inverted cross on it whose mother is
seen in all these crazy photo shoots
where she's doing every Illuminati
symbol there is wearing goat horns all
this stuff like this dude is satanic he
doesn't even hide it and he made a post
that said drone swarm battles are coming
that will Boggle the mine he said this
the end of September that means it was
going into October and here we are in
December and we're seeing this stuff
have been seeing this for like two weeks
or a month right now how did he know
this how did he predict this he's
Trump's right-hand man like they are
buds he invites Trump or he invites Elon
on stage to talk to the audience yeah
check this out Cliff High a computer
scientist and linguist spoke in a
YouTube video about his model's
prediction known as the 39 days to melee
that said a battle between humans and
aliens in the sky would occur 39 days
after a trigger incited the incident
what high calls what Cliff High calls
the temporal marker was podcaster Joe
Rogan's interview with President Donald
Trump okay so this guy he he's like this
genius scientist programmer guy and he I
haven't seen it I've just read about it
but he's got this device that can like
analyze all the information in the world
and can make accurate predictions and I
think he made it for like the stock
market he was trying to get a you know
heads up on the stock market but for
some reason I don't even know if he
asked it or what
but this device said that 39 day this
was he predicted this like years ago
2019 I think this thing said 39 days
after Trump is on an interview with Joe
Rogan there would be a melee in the sky
is that what it said yeah melee so it
says um hi said so we're going to have
we're going to we're going to have these
some kind of weird confrontation visible
contention which we could probably call
and term combat in the skies that will
show up and it'll show up at a
predictable point which is probably
something over a month and we'll put
down 30 days or 39 days something over a
month after the temporal marker of um
Trump and Rogan and that's just the
beginning of all this right so this guy
said this and sure enough Trump was on
Joe
Rogan Cliff High's model predicts that
there will be 39 days between okay did
we just read that no there'll be 39 days
between the temporal marker of Trump's
interview and the appearance of this
visible contention which he said would
eventually lead to melee
in this instance the visible contention
would be with space aliens or
alien
reproduction Vehicles
so this prediction said it's going to be
with aliens or alien
Vehicles the descriptors his model
tracked in 2009 so that's when it Happ
in 2009 indicated that the visible
contention would be UFOs fighting other
UFOs or UFOs fighting Jets so this
device in 2009 predicted for one that
Trump would be on a podcast with Joe
Rogan and that 30 to 39 days after that
we would be seeing some kind of battle
in the sky with aliens or alien Vehicles
crazy hi predicted that on December 3rd
visible contention between humans and
Aliens would begin eventually ending in
May
after the after an unspecified period
today's December 20th ironic man that
was the same date that space force
unrolled but I think these drones have
been being seen and here we
are um he predicted in December 3rd the
visible contention between humans and
Aliens would begin eventually ending in
melee after an unspecified period his
prediction model the webbot is a
computer program that allows individuals
to predict future events
by tracking keywords on the internet it
monitors internet chatter including
articles blogs forums and more according
to the
Telegraph and um then it finishes up
here it says hi created the computer
program in
1997 with his partner George er but said
he developed his theory regarding a war
between humans and aliens in 2009 the
prediction has since gone viral on
YouTube and X formerly Twitter with many
voicing their thoughts on his theory and
anticip and anticipation of war in the
skies like this is
crazy so Joe Rogan another influencer
with
18.8 million subscribers um last updated
this month so he's got 18.8 million
subscribers remember these influencers
on YouTube they're more famous than
movie stars like this is the new this is
the new propaganda platform influencers
like Logan Paul and Joe Rogan so check
this out here it is the Trump interview
with Rogan the that was prophesied in
2009 by this webbot thing there's a lot
of interest in it one of the things that
there's a lot of interest in uh the uh
people coming from space you know yes
and I know you're interested in that oh
I'm very interested in that how much
they tell you about that a lot really
yeah what' they tell you well it's never
been my thing I have to be honest I I
have never been a Believer I have people
that area 51 or whatever it is I think
it's the number one tourist attraction
in the whole country or something I I
interviewed jet Pilots that uh were
solid people the perfect I mean great
Pilots great everything and they said we
saw things s that were were very strange
like a round ball but it wasn't a com or
a meteor it was something and it was
going four times faster than an F22
which is a very fast plan you
know and it was round and it was round
so here it is again you know first on
Logan Paul he was saying the same thing
like I interviewed these beautiful
Perfect People he's just I don't know
why to him it makes you
more uh trustworthy or more credible if
you're beautiful and perfect but he
knows personally these jet pilots and
he's saying they told me that they've
seen things that defy physics there's no
humanly possible explanation for what
these things are and they're round
they're balls of light or something
that's the description they gave they
didn't say hey we're seeing these
saucer-like crafts that are made out of
metal and they got nuts and bolts they
didn't say that they said these are
round things glowing balls of light and
so I think that's interesting because
what are people
seeing the news is reporting this as
drones that's the terminology that the
news is saying we're not seeing drones I
don't know what people are seeing but
they're zooming in on things that don't
look like any kind of drone that we have
so the news is doing what they always do
they use this terminology like when I
was growing up everything that was seen
in the sky it was a weather balloon or
swamp gas or whatever but now to kind of
disarm the people they're saying oh
they're drones but it's purposeful it
this is purposeful
misinformation they want you to be upset
they they know you're not dumb and they
want you to say these aren't drones tell
us the truth why are you telling us that
these are drones for one why are you
telling us that these aren't ours and
they're not a foreign adversaries but to
still be just comfortable and not worry
there's things flying in the sky why
should we not worry if you don't know
what it is but that's this is this is
just how this misinformation propaganda
works this is the type of stuff that
people are actually seeing watch this
guy's clip people have been
photographing these strange UFOs or
drones and for some reason when you zoom
in they look almost like portals to
other dimensions or something this one
here has a bunch of strange lights and
striations throughout and it's glowing
white as gold
this one here kind of resembles the one
before but it's a bright cobalt
[Music]
blue this one here is a strange light
orb it almost looks like a blob of
colors and lights all morphed together
floating in the
sky so this is just how they these
people are so intelligent because Satan
is intelligent Satan has had thousands
of years to study human psychology like
what works and so part of how they do
all this stuff is they put out
information like real information but by
uncredible sources so remember that
magazine when you were in the grocery
store it was like National inquire bat
boy and all this kind of crazy stuff
they would actually put like real type
of stuff in there too
um and so that would make the the truth
about a subject like maybe a false flag
or something like that that would make
that subject look
discrediting too much National inquir
like what you know what so
disinformation misinformation propaganda
all this stuff This Is How They
psychologically this is psychological
warfare this is how they're manipulating
and controlling the masses into thinking
a certain way and believing a certain
narrative that these are drones
um here's something else that Trump said
in that same Joe Rogan interview I get
that question as much as almost any
question do you think that we have
aliens coming you know flying around or
whatever what do you think I mean
there's no reason not to think that Mars
and all these planets don't have life
you know solid beautiful people they
said sir there's something there you
know they there's something there they
said it yeah yeah I've talked to quite a
few of them they're not conspiracy guys
well I mean the just the commander David
fraver thing in 2004 off the coast of
San Diego they clocked that thing going
from 50,000 ft above sea level to Second
yeah they don't know what it is that's
tough a bit Yeah they they saw something
in the water it was hovering over that
something that was making a disturbance
in the water they got video evidence of
this thing two different fighter jets
with pilots in them saw it there's you
know Visual Evidence photographic
evidence video evidence radar evidence
whatever the hell it is it moves in a
way that would turn a human being into
if inside of it the gForce no one would
survive like what is that and we don't
it doesn't have a heat signature they
don't know what their propulsion system
was so yeah I'm seeing some great
comments come in somebody was saying
that they look just like stars do they
do when you zoom in on a
star it looks like for one it looks like
a light underwater which matches what
the Bible says but these flickering
lights that change color and they look
like water and so somebody was pointing
out that the Bible calls Angels Stars
it's symbolic meaning but I think maybe
these Fallen Angels this is the
appearance that they have or the
appearance that they're taking on right
now and as people are zooming in that's
what they're
seeing um so what what Joe Rogan just
got through saying was that these things
defy physics these things that people
are seeing defy
physics it's just mindboggling that Joe
Rogan is so close to the truth man he's
had interviews with thousands of people
and he's so close to the truth he he
sees that these are not physical beings
they can't be physical beings if they're
defying physics he just said that they
make 90 Dee angles at thousands of miles
and hours that would turn a human being
into Jello if they were flying that
thing so how can you believe in aliens
being physical beings from a far distant
Galaxy that are just traveling here this
this is
deceptive these are interd itional
deceivers that are creating a mythology
about themselves to to deceive Humanity
Satan is going to deceive the entire
world and this is how he's doing it he's
created this whole mythology about
aliens and that he's from another world
and if you get into biblical cosmology
that just destroys this whole narrative
and that's why I think it's an important
topic but some people don't and it's
triggering so I don't even want to get
into that but either way Satan is here
him and his angels are here they're
bound to this earth and yet they're
saying that they're coming from far
distance galaxies millions of light
years away but that's it's just a it's a
deception so when he's saying that these
things are defying physics that's a red
flag right there that these are not
physical in fact here's some footage of
these things defying physics someone
called the cops on these lights they're
going into the ocean is that it
[Music]
so these things are going right into the
water see even the police they're going
crazy I don't know of any craft that can
fly around and then go
underwater and then it looks just like
this other footage that was taken not
too much further from that somewhere in
Florida where they were seeing this
green glowing light the same colored
light under
water so here's a side by-side
comparison these lights are going into
the water and then they're being seen
from on top of the water you see it
driving underwater like I don't think
that's some scuba diver you know keeping
up with the boat I don't think it's some
submarine to me they look like they're
the same thing actually there's been
articles that are saying that these
things come in and out of the water
right here this New Jersey congressman
Smith uh addresses reports of 50 drones
emerging from the ocean including a
vessel leading 12 to 30 drones so these
are official reports saying that these
things are coming out of the water there
was a guy named William Cooper who wrote
a book called Behold a Pale Horse he was
uh he was in the military and he said
that he was on the ocean in a on a ship
and he was told that he can never speak
about what he's about to see and he saw
flying objects that would just smash
into the ocean and would not make a
splash would go like a thousand miles an
hour into the water and instead of just
shattering into pieces like it should
according to physics it went into the
water and he I think he even described
like it looked like the water just
opened up and let it in without making a
single Splash like this is not physical
but yet this is what's happening these
are the things that we're seeing now in
our current
world so check this video out because
this lady Zooms in on this quote unquote
drone and it looks like a star or some
kind of glowing orb and she begins to
talk to it and when she talks about
Jesus or God this thing reacts check
this out if I can do this
today where am I in between those two
trees
so maybe this is a star to me it doesn't
even look like it's moving but she
thinks it looks close I
guess see if I can zoom in
more I know I can but my fingers don't
work sorry guys
sorry guys here we go let's see if we
can see
that that looks like it's underwater
just like the
stars that's kind of
cool can you talk to me
can you hear
me Jesus Loves
Me whoa look at that oh you know
Jesus wow you know Jesus Jesus Is
Awesome isn't
he yes he
is look how it is right now God is
good
whoa God is
good God is
good so does that look like a drone that
doesn't look like a drone this is the
type of stuff that people are capturing
and the news is saying drones are out
here like crazy but all in the military
too it's not just the news even the mil
the news is just they're just going off
a scrip RT teleprompter say what you're
supposed to say talking ahead and and
they're getting their script from the
the military because this is what's
happening when there's these meetings
they're saying well we don't we don't
know what they are but uh there's no
need to have concern we're going to see
some clips like that but this new Ager
chick she's openly New Age um she
started having encounters with these
quote unquote drones or UFOs or whatever
and this is what we've talked about this
is what we've talked about on strange
normal this is what we talked about in
the documentary disclosed on Little
Light Studios 35 minute documentary
talks about all this stuff very well
produced very sharable information that
needs to get out to the world but when
you are messing around in the occult you
will have interactions with these things
because Satan is only allowed to go
where he's invited you know and so there
are rules of Engagement in the spiritual
world and that can come through many
different forms it could come through
some kind of pendant on a jewelry or
some kind of uh statue in your home
that's really an idol or dream catcher
or whatever any type of thing that you
could have in your house crystals and
stuff like that now listen to what this
chick says for one she's a new Ager for
another she has a wife and it's
interesting that she's having these
experiences when I woke up up it felt
like someone took a screwdriver up the
left side of my nose like it was
pounding pounding and my head was
pounding like severely pounding to the
point like for 3
weeks I didn't work I laid in bed like I
felt awful awful and it wasn't from a
sickness it wasn't flu or nothing it was
just my head was like pounding my nose
was
pounding and so um
um I I don't know what happened it looks
like the clip got cut off but she was
seeing something and she had some kind
of crazy headache that started with her
nose felt like a screwdriver up her nose
she said and she said her wife and kid
were gone and she was coming home from
work or something and this thing
followed her all the way home she said
and so she's like you know I've never
had this experience before but people
think I'm crazy and I don't want people
to judge me but I'm just telling you the
truth that I'm having these encounters
now here's a video of her and her son
zooming in on one of these things and
she's telling her child to talk to it
telling her child that they're aliens
and tell the aliens that we love them
and this thing reacts so here's a
question I want you to think about
if some other distant far distant Galaxy
out there has a planet and there's
little green men out there or physical
beings that are just like us but High
highly Advanced uh race of
beings why would they be able to hear
you why would they why would they appear
when you meditate why would they appear
when you ask to see them how would you
open yourself up and become a channel
for an alien to speak through you that
defies all physics all technology this
is a spiritual thing the Bible talks
about mediums and being a Channeler
that's all this is Satan in a new
disguise he came as a serpent in the
garden he's came as in the past of the
Egyptians he's came as raw and Horus and
Isis and all these beings that they have
etchings of and now he's coming as alien
graay flying these crazy looking ships
but listen to what she list just watch
this video what she's telling her kid to
say and the response of this entity in
the
sky I thought
talk if they'll like come
down will you ask them say if you can
hear us will you blink in and
out blink in out
[Music]
please I say it loud
yeah wait what did you say
say to the aliens in the sky we love you
we welcome you we love you oh my gosh it
blinked it blinked oh my gosh it's
blinking in and out oh my gosh oh my God
it's linking in and out for you Kai oh
they can hear us do you see that
yeah I oh my
gosh and so you know she's taught her
child that these beings are our friends
and welcome them they need to come you
know and she's like I love you I hope
you come and this is why we we read some
statistics on the last video about um
how like the high percentage of people
that believe in alien life now it wasn't
like that before back I watched an
interviewer go on the streets in the
black and white days and people when he
asked them if they believe in aliens
they said no that's sci-fi stuff well
now the majority of the population do
believe in extraterrestrials and the
majority of that percentage are the
young people under 30 because one
generation is teaching the younger
generation and that generation teaches
the next younger generation to where
this new AER chick who's having severe
headaches from this thing is telling her
5-year-old child that they're they're
friends to invite them we love you come
on wow man so here's
um this is a a drone supposedly they got
caught in a tree check out this
video still doesn't look like any kind
of drone I've ever seen before even
though it is does appear to be stuck in
a tree there for at least 4
hours this looks like
some cell under a microscope or
something
see definitely looks like it's like a
living organism I think it's just
the I never seen a drone like that
look at this
thing this is
not it's got a spotlight on it you can
see inside
it what is going on right
now this those drums I've been see in
New Jersey bide New Jersey Ocean
Township here we go Ed look at this
thing I don't know what it's
doing pops just got
later so if anybody's questioning like
what are my thoughts on this because I I
already saw some people saying like what
do you guys believe about this I believe
this is a combination of things I
believe that we have highly advanced
technology that the citizens have never
seen before that the public has never
seen seen before look how look how fast
technology has advanced in just the past
five years five years ago we couldn't
get on AI and say make me a picture of
anything I want and it happens or make
me a song about this and it sounds like
something on the radio the technology is
mindblowing and they've been making
Flying Saucer crafts since Nazi Germany
like that's how long they've been
creating things that we haven't seen
before the military is at least 10 years
ahead of us things that they give things
that we get commercial products like a a
cell phone that you can watch any movie
you want on it you can communicate you
can live stream like this that's just
the toys that they give us we have no
clue what kind of Technology they have
so I believe that some of this is
Advanced military craft and I believe
the other parts of this is this external
externalization of the
hierarchy um demons manifesting in our
world just like the Bible says the Bible
says that uh three unclean spirits like
frogs are going to go to the militaries
of the world and unite them together for
the battle against Christ how can that
happen unless it's really going to
happen I mean the Bible isn't lying
prophecy is true we're seeing it today
we're there and like I mentioned on the
last live stream I don't think that all
the military knows what's going on I
don't think that they understand that
this is demonic I think they do believe
they're under the spell of the deception
they believe that these are alien beings
and so that's why they're flying around
and there's been videos of helicopters
chasing after these orbs and um you know
the thing is is they're actually
Banning um drones they're banning the
use of Civilian drones so so that we
can't go up there and see what it is
like keeping more of this in
mystery check out this guy he actually
sent a drone up and something happened
to his drone last week or so two weeks
when it started I tried to take my drone
over patini Arsenal to follow a drone
that was just hovering over there and as
I got closer my drone lost power spun
out and the battery died and it went
down but the other drone remained
sitting in the air unaffected why what
do you think
no secrets that the government don't
want us to know and they're playing
stupid either that or alien so he flew
his drone up he said it was fully
charged and that thing dropped so either
these things have um either these are
military drones that have some kind of
force field capability that we don't
know anything about or he was getting
too close to fallen angels and they have
the power to do all kinds of stuff
people think that Satan is weak you
realize it was Satan in job's day that
brought down fire from heaven that
caused all these
sores that that just was like a
revelation to me right this moment thank
you Lord for that that even Satan can
make
plagues Satan caused sores to come upon
job so even like pandemics in the world
and all that Satan could pull those
things away and looked like he healed
people the Bible says there's going to
be a miracle working demons and so in
job's day he brought down fire from
heaven he caused sores to be all over
job's body and if he can do it he can
also take it away and make himself look
like a Healer of humanity and so yeah I
think this drone got too close to a
fallen angel or to some technology that
we're unaware of and his drone fell to
the
Earth so this is what I'm talking about
though like they are literally it says
the FAA bands drones in parts of New
Jersey this is all like I just took
these shots screenshots yesterday 15
hours ago 10 hours ago 6 hours ago so
this happened like a day ago as of
yesterday um the the government is
Banning drones from flying in parts of
New Jersey why because somebody doesn't
want us to fly up there and see what's
really going on that these are not
drones if if we have the technology to
fly and see whatever we want to this
would be no mystery right but they want
to keep the whole thing a
mystery so a lot of you have seen this
clip but I think it's a very prophetic
and valuable clip to watch check out
what uh Reagan said at the United
Nations on September 21st in
1987 in our obsession with antagonisms
of the moment we often forget how much
unites all the members of
humanity perhaps we need some outside
Universal threat to make us recognize
this common
bound I occasionally think how quickly
our differences worldwide would vanish
if we were facing an alien threat from
outside this
world and yet I ask you is not an alien
force already among
us so I mean Reagan was right there
saying we could bring about a new world
order if an alien Invasion came like
this is a United Nations meeting if you
believe in Bible prophecy you know that
there's going to be a one world
government and a one world religion and
so when you have a a president of the
world's most powerful Nation standing
before all the other leaders of the
world saying what could unite Humanity
an alien invasion and here we are in the
year
2025 where we are seeing things that we
can't explain in the skies
I don't care what the news is saying I
don't care what the military is saying
this is all psychological warfare this
is this is all them just trying to pull
the wool over your eyes like oh we don't
know what it is but just be calm oh it
could be we could be sniffing for bombs
whatever people are not seeing your
typical drone and that's the truth
that's that's what's happening right now
we're seeing the external hierarchy the
externalization of the hierarchy we're
seeing prophecy right now 2020
guys like it is the beginning of
something crazy are we ready for this
are are the Christians of this world
ready to face what's coming like face to
face with demonic entities who are
claiming to be the saviors of humanity
who are preparing us for a war against
an evil alien Invader which will be
Christ and All His angels are we ready
for that that I mean I don't think we
are you know I've known this is coming
for a long time but I don't know if I'm
ready to face that in
reality but all we can do is get close
to Christ get in the word know what's
happening not be deceived and tell as
many people as we can about the truth of
what's coming which is why this book is
so important this kids book that's
coming
out I cannot wait for this aby's strange
dreams to come out this children's book
the first children's book that teaches
about spiritual warfare and what aliens
are and what
angels and demons and dragons and all
that is because so many kids movies are
saying dragons are your pet friend
aliens are your friend monsters like
Cookie Monster and Elmo they're your
friends nobody is teaching the truth to
these kids about aliens and fallen
angels and dragons and monsters so I'm
so thankful that God has inspired you
guys to raise enough money to print
2,000 copies of this book let's get this
book out to the world
so Carol Rosen she was the speaker
for Warner Von Bron in his last dying
years he Warner Von Bron was a Nazi
scientist that helped form NASA and in
his last dying years he admitted some
things he confessed some things to her
because he he had to get it off his
chest and he said they're going to
weaponize space space force ring a bell
when your pointed weapons towards the
heavens you're weaponizing space you're
preparing a battle against Christ and
this guy knew it was happening because
he was an Insider and he said the way
they're going to do it is first they're
going to say we need to protect you from
Russians and terrorists then they're
asteroids and he laughed about that
because he knew asteroids aren't even
the news is all the time pushing that
fear an asteroid might come and hit
Earth and that oh we close one we almost
got hit but we never saw anything and
then the UFO would be the the final card
check it out when I was a corporate
manager of Fairchild Industries in 1974
through 77 I met the late Dr verer Von
Brown in early
74 Von Brown's purpose in life during
the last years of his life has Dying
Years was to educate the public and
decision makers about why space-based
weapons are a dumb dangerous
destabilizing too costly unnecessary
unworkable undesirable
idea the strategy that verer Von Brown
taught me was that first the Russians
are going to be considered to be the
enemy in fact when I met him in 74 they
were the enemy the identified enemy we
were told that they had killer
satellites we were told that they were
coming to get us in control us the dirty
commies that whole story first the
Russians were the enemy against whom
we're going to build space-based weapons
then terrorists would be identified and
that was soon to follow we heard a lot
about
terrorism then we were going to identify
third world country crazies We Now call
them nations of concern but he said that
would be the third enemy against whom we
would be needing to build space-based
weapons and the next enemy was asteroids
now at this point he kind of chuckled
the first time he said it asteroids
against asteroids were going to build
space-based weapons so it was funny then
and the funniest one of all was against
what he called aliens extraterrestrials
that would be the final card
and over and over and over during the
four years that I knew him and was
giving his speeches for him he would
bring up that last card and remember
Carol the last card is the alien card
we're going to have to build space-based
weapons against aliens and all of it he
said is a
lie so that's exactly what happened in
December 20th 2019 when Trump under the
Trump Administration we got the space
force that interview was from years ago
I don't even know the date of that
interview but this guy was telling her
he was an Insider and he was saying
they're going to tell the world there's
aliens and we need space based weapons
the weapons are to fight
Christ this is Bible prophecy that the
world will Unite with deceiving Miracle
workking demons and Humanity will be
deceived by the lying sign and wonders
many will depart from the faith giving
heed to seducing spirits and doctrines
of demons and Unite with demons who are
masquerading as alien visitors who want
to protect Earth from the threat that's
coming from Heaven this is where we're
at we are living in Revelation right now
it's
mindblowing
so here is a uh a summary of behold a
Pale Horse written by William Cooper
listen what he said William Cooper's
perspective on UFOs and aliens because
let me tell you something real quick
this guy totally believed in Aliens like
he was in like he was in the military
seeing UFOs do crazy things Maneuvers
he's never seen before and he was like
Wow aliens are real but then the more he
looked at it the more he caught on to
something and it's actually explained in
here William Cooper's perspective on
UFOs and aliens evolved significantly
over time
initially as an a naval intelligence
officer he claimed to have seen
classified documents and been briefed on
UFOs and extraterrestrials which led him
to believe in their existence he
described observing crafts that appeared
to defy the laws of physics reinforcing
his early convictions however as Cooper
delved deeper into research and
reflection he became increasingly
skeptical of the alien narrative he came
to the conclusion that the UFO
phenomenon was being being used as a
form of psychological warfare and
deception by powerful Elites Cooper
argued that the alien narrative was a
smoke screen to manipulate public
perception and distract from covert
governmental agendas such as the
establishment of a totalitarian New
World Order oh my goodness that's where
we're at today in his later years Cooper
contended that the UFO and alien
phenomenon were part of a long-term
disinformation campaign designed to
instill fear and justify the development
of advanced Weaponry that's exact look
this is a fear tactic to justify having
weapons pointed towards space towards
the
heavens so it says to instill fear and
justify the development of advanced
Weaponry
surveillance drones anyone and control
systems under the guise of protecting
Humanity from an ex extra terrestrial
threat oh my goodness that is where
we're at today the overwhelming
abundance of weaponry and surveillance
and it's all for your protection peace
and safety to keep you protected from an
extraterrestrial threat he believed that
some of the Unexplained aerial
phenomenon were either Advanced
human-made Technologies or outright
Fabrications ultimately Cooper viewed
the alien narrative as a pool of
deception aligning it with his broader
critiques of global conspiracies and
government manipulation his shift in
perspective underscores his distrust of
Institutions and their potential use of
mythologies to control the masses wow
that was
deep the instit their potential use of
mythologies to control the masses I mean
this has been going on for years you
look at um the papacy the papacy used
mythology to control the people if you
don't give money to us your family
members are going to burn and burn and
burn in purgatory but if you give us
money you can shave off a little time of
their suffering come on bring in the
money I mean they told people that the
end of the world was coming if they
didn't give them their whole farms and
everything and people gave them
everything and when the world didn't
come to an end people said hey can we
get our stuff back and they're like no
you gave it to God like mythology being
used to control the masses to enslave
Humanity so like I said this stuff's
been going on for a long time these
crafts these UFO shaped Flying Saucer
things man these things have been around
since Nazi Germany and our us uh had
these too US Air Force right there so
you know there's a there's a combination
of things being seen people if they see
this it could potentially just be a
secret craft if they're seeing orbs I
believe
that's I believe that's satanic that's
fallen angels masquerading and
manifesting over the cities of the
world and it's all this propaganda we've
been fed this garbage our whole life
from Aliens to Starship Troopers Men In
Black Stargate like how many movies are
about aliens and this is just that's an
old screenshot I mean the movies just
keep coming out out all to program you
to believe when you see a glowing orb in
the sky there's little green men in
there driving that thing from another
world physical beings that are just here
to protect us because you know what that
these sightings blew up after the first
testing of the nuclear bomb or the atom
bomb and so people really believe like
insiders and stuff they believe that
these beings came to Earth to protect us
from destroying ourselves they've said
that during the war they these UFO
things have deactivated nuclear warheads
so even the military is deceived in
believing that these things are have our
best interest and I think it's taken
years and years and generations of
interacting with the military to build
that trust because now they can say well
why' we disarm that nuke you know how
come we've been giving you all our
secrets our technology and all this
stuff trying to get the the militaries
of the world the elites to side with
them and I believe they are at this
point so check out this is like stuff
that's going on right now um to be clear
uh that we we tried to turn that pretty
quickly um what we are looking for in
there he was asked are these Department
of Defense assets uh he said no none of
them are was the follow-up he said no he
is confirming again on the record these
are not military DRS drones John in the
past few years the allpurpose term
drones has replaced swamp gas and
weather balloons as the military's go-to
explanation for unknown objects and what
might be the most ironic of the current
sightings intrusions by so-called drones
caused air traffic at Wright Patterson
Airbase to shut down this weekend Wright
Pat is where the wreckage from the 1947
Roswell crash was reportedly stored nice
touch drone people we have no evidence
at this time that the reported drone
sightings pose a national security or a
public safety threat or have a foreign
Nexus an assortment of government
officials have tried to quell public
concerns in recent weeks but the public
isn't buying it and the Mystery drones
didn't get the memo either social media
platforms are jam-packed with cell phone
videos of assorted lights and odd
objects seen nightly in the Skies over
New Jersey and many other States
including Florida Texas California and
Oregon most are likely the lights of
airplanes but some do resemble standard
drones albeit a few the size of an SUV
they do not perform like known drones
New Jersey officials have demanded
briefings and say they were told that
drones are not a threat are not being
flown by the US government are not being
flown by Foreign adversaries and by the
way the government is unable to track
them doesn't know where they originate
or where they go each morning it was the
biggest Amateur hour presentation I've
ever seen about anything okay it was
ridiculous there were no answers uh
every question that was asked by the a
member of the state legislature great
questions no answers no resolution they
don't know where the drones are coming
from they don't know who's doing it they
don't know why they're doing it but they
say there's no credible threat it was
annoying that is not an airplane in the
absence of credible information rumors
have swirled maybe they're from Russia
or China or an Iranian Mother Ship
parked offshore or maybe it's a secret
operation by the feds to quietly track
down a dirty bomb or nuclear material
smuggled into the country by terrorists
officials have tried to quash such
rumors but their credibility has been
impaired just days ago the public was
told there were zero verified drone
intrusions into restricted airspace over
military bases then in a statement just
days later from multiple agencies
including the FBI and the military it
was admitted there have been intrusions
by unknown drones over two New Jersey
military sites also confirmed drone
intrusions over a nuclear power plant
prior to the new Jersey outbreak mystery
drones repeatedly flew into the highly
restricted airspace over three critical
air bases in the UK so what gives it's a
serious deal man we got a uh I think
it's a it's a test somebody's testing us
and we're failing that
test who who's testing us did that make
any sense I mean there the news is
literally saying well the news is just
reporting what the military is saying
but they're saying this isn't ours it's
not a foreign adversary we don't know
where they're coming from we can't track
them but hey don't worry about it it's
all good this will all pass just keep
shopping carry on just you know watch TV
watch another reality show and this
isn't just happening in New Jersey like
a lot of that's that's the big thing
right now New Jersey New Jersey but they
it's Florida It's Brazil it's like all
over the world this is worldwide there
are parts that are getting more
recognition more um
publicity about it but this stuff is
happening worldwide this is crazy
somebody in here said they don't believe
that nukes are what what we are told um
I don't believe nukes as we're told
actually exist no evidence of ever being
used and seems odd no one would have
used one it's a fear game I actually
have come to that belief as well I've
seen videos of a scientist who literally
takes spoon fools of radium and eats it
puts a geiger meter to his tongue and
it's going off like crazy and he's been
doing this for years um this might seem
way out there but just look into the
idea of nuclear um weapons that can you
know we've been told since I was a kid
that we can we have the technology to
blow the world up like eight times over
it's all fear Satan wants to keep you in
fear that's what all this is about man
these Chinese they they go down the
streets with and parade these big
nuclear missiles down the road and all
for all we know it's an empty Silo like
there's no proof of this stuff at all so
that's that's another uh Rabbit Trail
right there but this stuff right here
about we don't know what they are we
don't know where they're coming from but
hey um the fact that they don't know
what they are that should be a red flag
right there been more drone sightings
across the country the latest report in
New York New Jersey and Maryland the
White House says there is no evidence of
reported drones pose any threat but
that's uh doing little to calm concerns
people in Southern California are also
reporting mysterious drone sightings and
one person captured video of lights over
to mecula so that clip was just to show
that this is not just New Jersey they're
saying mystery drones from coast to
coast I got a text right before I went
live that they're seeing them here now
somebody's like it's happening in
Chattanooga Tennessee so it's everywhere
listen to what Rosio Donald says now can
we stop calling them drones they're
obviously UFOs people come on it's all
over the world now it's not just in a
little thing in New Jersey just saw one
from China today it's all over the world
what do you think that some country Iran
has the capacity and the capability to
Monitor and fly these drones all over
the world at the same time doing the
Maneuvers that they're doing I mean
not trying to scare everybody but
they're here they're here and the powers
that be don't want to acknowledge that
because that leaves them with a higher
authority nobody's going to care about
Trump or Putin or all of the strong men
in the world who are dictators and cruel
and evil no they're not going to have
the power that they had if if this is
true the aliens are here and they're
obviously Superior to us in many many
ways
let's hope they don't want to just you
know blow us up let's hope and I wonder
why I'm not sleeping right but I think
it's
ridiculously head in the sand to think
these are drones that are from another
that just happen to be all over the
world at the same time it it makes no
sense people it makes no sense you can't
be afraid to look at the truth that's
what I say you got to face it head on
right and what's the the truth here
there
are so many in the skies above our
planet and the government is not having
daily press conferences to tell us what
the is going
on question that a lot I question that a
lot yeah I mean I actually agree with
her not the fact that they're aliens but
think about that word alien the very
definition of the word alien means not
from this place right and so Satan is an
alien I mean he's here now but he he
didn't originate from Earth he is by
definition an alien so Satan has
literally taken the word
angels and turned it into alien and that
just everything's been thrown off like
there are people who believe in the
whole alien thing and they say there's
good there's good aliens and there's bad
aliens and there's a cosmic war going on
all around us you know how close to the
truth that is
like that's the truth there is a cosmic
war going on there is good angels and
bad Angels Waring right now trying to
get our Allegiance trying to get our
attention um trying to well the evil
angels are trying to deceive humanity
and the good angels are trying to get
our attention for the truth and to wake
us up so there literally is a cosmic war
going on but Satan has just Twisted the
terminology just enough
to to throw us off it's like um you know
any kind of ship or you know a ship on a
ocean if that little tongue in the back
whatever the thing the rotor in the back
is shifted just a little bit you'll be
going the wrong in a few hours
completely the wrong direction just by a
little
change and so I actually believe what
Rosie O'Donald's saying here like these
aren't drones these things are coming up
all over the world for one we don't have
enough I don't know I don't maybe we do
maybe they're hidden in bunkers or
something but that's a lot of drones I
think something else is going on
here President Biden and his
administration say whatever it is that
people are seeing up in the sky it poses
no threat how do they know they've
admitted that these things are real that
they're flying around we don't know
where they're from we don't know where
they're going we don't know who's behind
it we we don't think it's foreign
adversarial and it's not ours and yet
for someone to turn around and say it's
not a threat that the federal government
is not being honest with the American
people chalking all these drones up as
legally operated vehicles and aircraft
and law enforcement if that's the case
they would not be shutting down military
installations because of drone
incursions it's just it just simply does
not make
sense it doesn't make sense and so this
guy Lou Alex Lou alzando he is the
poster boy for this whole thing like he
former head of the Pentagon he's all
about this UFO thing he's doing
conferences me and Brad from strange
normal and Aubry are supposed to go and
watch one of these conferences so that
we can pass out cards with Starfall
movie and disclosed documentary and get
the truth out there to people who are
just buying into this they're sucking
this stuff up they're eating it up like
the truth because this guy is like an
Insider but he had a higher up tell him
that these things were demonic and he's
still lost he's still not believing it
or understanding it but he's telling the
truth right here when he's saying this
isn't this can't be what the narrative
is that we don't know what they are and
it's it's okay to just feel safe about
it the bottom line is that civilian
drones don't fly in controlled us
airspace over restricted areas they're
not supposed to we're seeing a rash of
this I have videos on my phone from
Andrews Air Force Base Langley Air Force
Base um I I wish the Pentagon and and
this Administration would be consistent
with their messaging because all it's
doing is turning people really away from
trusting their government at a time by
the way where trust is already at a at a
historical low yeah exactly like people
don't trust the government anymore and
so you know it's really crazy
how how smart they are with this psych
psychological warfare like I think
they're literally purposely trying to
get us to distrust
them they want us to know that they're
lying so that we will feel empowered to
say tell us the truth and the truth
they're going to give us is well our
alien friends are here and we didn't
want to shock people because you
remember that that thing that happened
War of the world's radio show a graphic
novel went on the radio and it was on
Halloween and every commercial break
they said this is a Halloween broadcast
blah blah blah but it s the whole thing
sounded like a news an an ER describing
an alien invasion and you'd hear sound
effects and the they'd be like oh the
alien is getting out and he's hideous oh
people committed suicide when they
listen to that there were people that
just couldn't handle the fact like I
don't want to come face to face with one
of these things I don't want to be
tortured by one I'm GNA off myself that
was a long time ago like in the 30s so
they already know how we're going to
respond to certain things and I I think
even that was probably a psychological
Warfare operation they were trying to
test the public how will the Republic
respond to an alien invasion and so
they're trying to warm us up to the idea
get them comfortable with the drones you
know if we can get them to be
comfortable with the the quote unquote
drones if we can get them to just keep
going on with life and keep shopping and
keep working while the drones are flying
overhead then hey we can finally tell
them that the aliens have been here this
whole time and they would have hurt us
by now right they haven't hurt us all
this time they got to be friendly they
got to be on our side it's it's this
frog in the kettle thing turning up the
heat a little bit it's all about getting
you desensitized to the idea of having
these things this has been predicted in
movies the the the series on Sci-fi
channel called V the UFOs just hovered
over cities for days and weeks to let
the people just get used to it before
they finally came out and revealed
themselves crazy so here's this quote
unquote whistleblower who's saying we've
been talking to non-human intelligences
for years you are alleging that the US
government has been concealing the
existence on this planet of alien
life I would couch it as non-human
intelligence you know nhi like we like
to say in our our language why do you
say that why do you say nhi I don't want
to necessarily denote origin I don't
think we have all the data to say oh
they're coming from a certain a certain
location and I and I I couch it as
somebody who studied physics where maybe
they're coming from a different physical
Dimension as described in quantum
mechanics we know there's extra
Dimensions due to high uh high energy
particle collisions Etc and there's a
theoretical framework to explain that
yeah just let me cut to the quick though
you're saying there is an intelligent
species engaging with this planet yes
that's potentially extraterrestrial yeah
I speak for everybody sitting at home
that is a shock it was to me and uh I
had a lot of sleepless nights I had a
lot of sleepless nights because we're
communicating with non-human
intelligences that are possibly
interdimensional beings yeah you should
lose sleep over that you should not be
communicating with these things and yet
it's happening and they're actually
admitting it to us like I said there's
no such thing as a whistleblower on
controlled media propaganda but the fact
that they want this man to come out if
it is controlled and it is Media
propaganda this is the narrative that
they want you to believe they want you
to believe in the existence of
aliens they want you to believe that the
military is communicating with these
things because that's how we're going to
accept demonic beings in our
world we have to understand or we have
to believe well the military's been
talking to him for years so they must be
trustworthy the military is smart and
they've been having Communications with
them we can trust these beings Satan has
to BU has to build up trust Satan has to
deceive the world into accepting him and
his fallen angels and that's where we're
at today that's what's happening right
now so Demi lado another huge
influencer um she has 18.1 million
subscribers and she's the one that's
like getting on Kesha's show and and
telling her how to meditate and channel
aliens but you know Rec before that she
was a Christian here she is on Kelly
Clarkson show listen to what she said so
I woke up in my room and there was like
three beings and then and they they were
like do you want to see your planet and
I was like oh sorry sorry you were like
I was like hell yeah let's go so so I
like whooshed out of my room and was
like hovering over the planet and then
all of a sudden they were like you want
to see our planet and I was like
yeah then I whoosh to this like pink and
purple planet that I've never seen But
and then and so that with the
hypnotherapy I was like trying to figure
out what exactly that was was it like I
don't want to use the word abduction
because that implies that it wasn't with
consent I was totally for it you know
what I'm saying
yes dude that is just crazy clip she's
saying I don't want to call it an
abduction because I was consenting dude
Dem lado grew up a
Christian and in
2019 I I'll show you this this is
crazy CBN News broadcast said Dei lado
being baptized in Israel filled
god-sized hole in my heart she did this
whole Instagram post back in 2019 I'm
pretty sure let me look at the date here
yeah October 2019 the end of 2019 she
went to Israel she got baptized she
wrote this whole article about how such
an amazing experience being in the very
place the same place that Jesus was and
being baptized in the same river that he
was in and she's like this is filled of
spiritual emptiness that I've had in my
heart for a long
time that was 20 that was the end of
2019 and now she's saying we can Channel
aliens and we can go on to a field and
meditate and they'll appear and it's and
it's happened to me and now I get beings
that visit me in my room three beings
come in and I give them my consent to
take me out into the universe and show
me all the planets in the world or in
the universe and that's one reason why I
do believe that biblical cosmology and
the understanding that is very important
but it's not a Salvation issue you can
be a Christian and believe the opposite
of what the Bible teaches about where we
live but this is one reason why I think
it's very important it is an important
topic so she was a Christian and she
went just downward spiral fast she
actually has a couple shows on TV or
peacock
television starting in 2021 so remember
she got baptized at the end of 20 2019
and now she's already got a show in
2021 it takes a long time to record
stuff to get it ready to be aired I mean
it takes years sometimes so from 2019
became a Christian baptized in the
Jordan River to 2021 there's a series
ready to show the public called
unidentified and it's all about
contacting
aliens but the the latest well not the
latest she's actually had like an album
or two since then but she released an
album of her laying on mattresses dirty
mattresses in the shape of a cross and
the album is called holy f word and the
one of the songs has this for the lyrics
like a serpent in the garden I am the
truth I am Darkness I'm an angel I'm a
demon just depends on what you're
feeling I'm the fruit that was forbidden
but don't keep my evil hidden I'm the
one she's afraid of I'm the one she was
afraid of now I'm what your dreams are
made of I'll show you the light with all
the lights off with all the lights off
I'll show you the light with all the
lights off are you kidding me she says
I'll bring you the life I am a holy I am
a holy and she's saying the f word there
the next verse says you see me begging
for
permission That's what Satan has to do
he has to get permission just like she
had to give permission let me free you
from her prison she's a novice a
beginner I'm the sexorcist The
Sinner I can guide you I can teach you
honey this is just a preview cuz my body
is the communion take a bite of what I'm
doing I didn't even fully read all this
until just now but this is like the most
Blasphemous album this is just one track
and the the album cover is Blasphemous
like it got banned in the UK they
wouldn't even allow this to be
shown
and this is a girl who was baptized in
the Jordan River in the end of 2019
how does that happen that's the question
how do you go from being a born again
Christian on National Television being
baptized on the Jordan River to
literally like a year later channeling
aliens having your own show about
talking to aliens and writing a album
like this how does that
happen because 1 Timothy 41 and 2 says
now the spirit expressively says that in
the latter times some will depart from
the faith you can't depart from
something you never had this is a woman
who departed from the faith why giving
heed to deceiving spirits and doctrines
of demons when she started be opening up
her mind to hm I wonder if I could
meditate and see an alien and it
happened she began to fall for the
deceiving spirits and the doctrines of
demons speaking lies and ocy having
their own conscience seared with a hot
iron she grew up in the truth so the
truth is your conscience your conscience
is the holy spirit telling you what's
right and wrong but her conscience has
now been seared because
she gave heed to seducing spirits and
doctrines of demons and departed from
the faith this is going to happen in the
latter times to millions of Christians
if they're not grounded in the truth and
they don't understand how Christ is
going to return in what way is he going
to return
um how Satan is going to appear how
Satan is going to have power to do signs
and wonders and even
Miracles if Christians don't understand
that they will fall for this deception
they will fall for the counterfeit
because this is something Supernatural
that we've never experienced in our
entire lives and this is why it's so
important to be in God's word Ephesians
612 says for we wrestle not against
flesh and blood but against
principalities against Powers against
the rulers of darkness of the darkness
of this age or sometimes it says World
against spiritual host of wickedness in
Heavenly
places wickedness is flying around in
our atmosphere in the Heavenly places
the Bible's literally telling us what is
happening today let no man deceive you
by any means for that day shall not come
except there come a falling away first
we're seeing the falling away in the
secular world and in the Christian world
and that man of sin be revealed the son
of predition so this is prophecy upon
prophecy that's being fulfilled right
here Revelation 12:9 says and the Great
Dragon was cast out that old serpent
called the devil and Satan which
deceives the whole
world drones are popping up around the
world quote unquote drones I hate even
using that word because they're not
drones that is just some sugar coded
word to make you feel halfway safe these
are demonic spirits manifesting as
glowing orbs coming up all around the
world to deceive Humanity into thinking
that demons are your friends and that
they're going to help us they're going
to do lying signs and wonders Miracles
and eventually bring us together for a
battle against the second coming of
Christ Revelation 131 13-14 says and he
doeth great wonders so that he makes
Fire come down from heaven on the earth
and the sight of men and deceiveth them
that dwell on the Earth by the means of
those Miracles it's the Mir deceive the
people because they're buying into their
senses believing what they see with
their own
eyes which he had power to do in the
sight of the Beast Matthew 24:24 says
for there shall arise false christs and
false prophets that's what these are
they're they're coming as the cosmic
saviors and shall show great signs and
wonders in so much that if it were
possible they shall deceive the very
elect are we a part of that elect are we
a part of the remnant that is smaller
than just being a Christian it doesn't
mean I believe in Jesus I go to church
every week I'm a part of that elect
right I'm a part of that Remnant I don't
believe that the Bible says that many
will say to me in that day Lord Lord
didn't we do all these proph didn't we
prophesy in your name and do many great
wonders in your name and he says depart
from me I never knew you you workers of
lawlessness it's more than just
believing you have to get in God's word
you have to sharpen that sword of the
spirit you got to commune with God you
got to fellowship with God you got to be
in the truth because the Bible says they
had not a love of the truth and so he
gave them over to this strong delusion
that they might be lost because they had
not a love of the truth the candid
truth Luke 21 25-
28 says and there shall be signs in the
Sun and in the moon and in the Stars
where is that that's in the skies that's
in the heavens we're seeing signs right
now and upon the Earth distress of
nations with perplexity the Sea and the
waves roaring men's Hearts failing them
for fear something's going to be in the
heavens that's so fearful that men are
going to die of a heart attack and for
looking after those things which are
coming on the Earth
like oh no what's coming on the earth
I'm dead because I just had a heart
attack for the powers of Heaven shall be
shaken and then shall they see this is
the good part this is the good part guys
all of this kind of drudgery and bad
news to find out the good part and then
shall they see the son of man coming in
a cloud with power and great glory and
when these things begin to come to pass
then look up and lift your heads for
your Redemption draws nigh that's what's
coming next
guys yes there are crazy things going on
in the world and have been for a while
but 29 2020 was like man that was like
some a line in the sand like things
started getting really bad the whole
world got turned upside down mask up six
feet apart take this shot space for
course but 2025 is like a new paradigm
shift like entities an externalization
of a
hierarchy there's writings prophetic
writings that say that Heathen deities
are going to manifest themselves and
parade themselves over the cities of the
world and that they're calling
themselves visitors from other worlds
but they are nothing more than the
spirits of
devils are we there
I leave that question to you
guys do you think we're there
now I 100% believe that we're there
Revelation 161 13- 14 says and I saw
three unclean spirits like frogs I think
that's an interesting description to
give these unclean devil spirits come
out of the mouth of the dragon out of
the mouth of the Beast out of the mouth
of the false prophet for they are the
spirits of devils what are they doing
they're working miracles and they're
going forth unto the kings of the Earth
the leaders of this world these beings
are communicating with and going to each
and every King of the
earth and the whole world to gather them
to the battle of the great day of God
Almighty that's what's coming this is
not a conspiracy theory guys this is
prophetic this is right here in the
Bible we are living in Revelation
chapter 16 right now hands down Case
Closed we're there I hope that this
video Prov that to you please share this
documentary with your family and friends
it's 35
minute uh very well produced documentary
style format that takes you through like
what could this be every angle is it
physical is it spiritual why do new
agers see them why do the occultist see
them why are people getting uh put back
in their bed when they're being abducted
when when they call upon the name of
Jesus like these
are these are evidences for what this is
that these are deceiving spirits in the
last days that are causing many to
depart from the faith because they're
giving heed to seducing spirits and
doctrines of De demons so if this
presentation was eye opening to you if
it made sense please give it a thumbs up
it really helps this video reach the
world there's a lot of deceived people
out there there's a lot of people asking
questions right now they need to know
that the Bible has the answers and if
you think that this is too long of a
format then please go to Little Light
Studios and find this disclosed
documentary and share this with them if
you guys feel led to give to this
ministry we are a self-supporting
Ministry we I guess that's the
terminology you use we are a 508
nonprofit you get tax deductible gift if
you want to but you can give to this
ministry through cash app through vinmo
through zel you can go to candid
truth.org and click on the Donate button
and if you like t-shirts we got t-shirts
you can go to our canat truth.org you
can click on shop and and buy some cool
shirts we get like $5 per shirt from
those orders I hope this was eye opening
for you guys I hope it made sense I hope
it lit a fire under you that we're in
the last days it's time to stop being
like one foot in the church one foot in
the world or just
lukewarm you know there's 10 virgins in
a parable that Jesus told 10 virgins
describe 10 Christians and they have
lamps with oil in them they had wisdom
and the Holy Spirit that was the
symbolic the symbol of the holy spirit
is the oil and they are trying to make
it to the wedding because we are the
bride of Christ and Christ is coming for
us and we want to make it to that
wedding so we should be one of those vir
wearing the white and we need to have
our lamps trimmed we need to have oil in
those lamps because five of The Virgins
fell asleep
half half of the church fell asleep and
when they woke up it was too late they
tried to get oil from the others and
they said we can't give you our oil we
have just enough to make it there go buy
some oil and come back and it they ran
out of time that's where we're at right
now we are in the time of the the
parable of the 10 virgins our husband is
coming the Prince of Peace the King of
Kings the Lord of Lord is is coming and
we need to be ready for his soon to come
appearing if you want that if that's you
and you want to be ready I pray that
right now you'll take that challenge
that you'll surrender things in your
life that you know are keeping you apart
from Christ whether it's a movie
Addiction whether it's pornograph it's
adulterous relationships whatever it is
that's holding you back from having that
solid relationship with God today is the
day of
salvation lay those things down and
surrender your life to Christ he removed
addiction out of my life in an instant
overnight no withdrawals because I
surrendered to him my testimonies on
this channel if you want to check it out
but I was
uh I was an
alcoholic addict fornicating
rapper and God changed my life overnight
New Year's 2013 because I surrendered
everything to him I said I am weak but
you are strong take this out of my life
I don't want it anymore God is not a
thief he's not taking anything away from
you that you're cherishing in any kind
of way he's knocking on the door of your
heart he's not bashing in doors you have
to answer the door and open the door of
your heart to allow him in he's waiting
on that he's longing for that we are the
ones that are choosing to walk away like
the prodical son I pray this was a
blessing to you please give it a thumbs
up if you're new click the Subscribe
button click the notification Bell we'll
see you next time on candid truth